you've worked with everybody I am as a
kid was fascinated with comedy my dad
took me to see ten from your show of
shows with you and and mr. Sid Caesar
and that changed my life and and so I
became a student of a lot of these
people when I was a kid there was a real
resurgence George Burns George Burns had
been a big star in the 40s the 50s and
the 60s and then in the 70s he became
huge and this massive star and he was on
The Muppet Show and in movies like Oh
God and you worked with him well we did
Oh God because you did Oh God and when
we decided who was gonna play Oh God the
first name was thrown to me was George -
of course he's God
yeah and his show and when George Burns
and Allen show he always was outside the
house telling you what's gonna happen in
the envelope was you had yes an
intelligence about him and I there's one
story I don't know if I can tell it
about George about George yeah there are
no children in the audience no children
in the audience no well there's Andy and
I were there but we he was a dear dear
man as a matter of fact one little story
about it we changed the scene one day
and I said little George we're gonna do
a different scene today so you better
remember pieces I memorized the whole
script he memorized the whole and he
would have been in his late 80s or not
he was in he was he was in the slate it
ad maybe something yeah okay the last
day of shooting I went into his trailer
to say goodbye to him at night I said
George I like your question I said I
wouldn't wonder what I have to look
what's in store for me sexually I said I
always see you you're 80 now I was 60 at
the time I I said I always see you with
two girls on the arm going out to dinner
I said what do I have to look forward
sexually and he said to me Kyle ever try
to put an oyster in a slot machine
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what a lovely anecdote you know I'm
thinking now I'm thinking now when I
first was on television there's sensors
yeah we did the show shows
Sid Caesar and I were in a sketch we
were being bombed in the world war one
the Germans are dropping bombs on us and
Sid is yelling at this at the heavens he
says damn you damn you and the sensor
says you can't say damn right we
couldn't say damn so darn you
darn you yeah cuz we had to say yeah
yeah and here I said that here yeah you
know it all changed the whole thing
change I love it a Berlin Wall fell
you